(upbeat music)
- Good morning guys.
The first video I ever
uploaded to YouTube,
was my morning routine
and you turned it into a smash hit.
Now, a lot has changed in my life
within the last year.
I have my new puppy Bear,
I finished my residency
and I'm practicing as a
Board-Certified doctor.
So I decided to give you
my updated morning routine
with the help of my new
Lenovo Smart Display,
with the Google Assistant.
Shout out to Lenovo, for
sponsoring this video.
Let's get started.
My mornings often start very early
with the alarm clock ringing
and really taking me out of a deep sleep.
Don't hit that snooze button.
It's gonna make you feel groggy
and make it even harder
to wake up in the morning.
The first thing that I
do once I get out of bed
is open the shades.
You want that natural light hitting you
as soon as you wake up.
Not only does it make it
easier for you to wake up
but it also resets your circadian rhythms
so you can fall asleep easier at night.
Next, I make my bed.
Now this hasn't changed from
my previous morning routine
and for good reason.
Both psych and military experts alike
recommend making your bed.
It yields tremendous productivity
and willpower benefits throughout the day.
Once my bed is all done,
I go on to brush my teeth.
You should be doing this twice a day,
and not only is it important
for your dental health,
but we've seen relationships
between heart disease
and those who don't take
care of their teeth.
Something I know a lot of
people skip out on is flossing.
Now I have braces in the back of my teeth,
so it's not so easy to floss,
but I use a Waterpik flosser.
It does the same job, shooting out
a high speed stream of water,
getting that gunk out
from in between my teeth.
Hey Google, good morning.
- [Google Assistant]
Good morning Doctor Mike.
It is 7:02am.
Today it'll be cloudy with
a forecasted high of 69
and a low of 59.
- Gonna be cold.
- [Google Assistant] By the way,
you need to film YouTube morning routine.
Also, don't forget to go to your meeting.
- The Lenovo Smart Display
with Google Assistant
has my entire schedule in it.
It has my reminders, the weather
updates, traffic updates.
In the morning when you're tired,
and you need your routine to be on point,
this thing has it all in one place.
Wait, where's Bear?
Hey, hey puppy.
Good morning little Bear.
I love you.
Good morning, good boy.
Yeah, good morning.
I know Bear, I feel the same way.
You ready to eat?
Who's ready to eat?
This is my morning routine right here.
Shower with the dog,
and then shower in the
bathroom afterwards.
Good boy. Yeah.
(dog chewing)
So, Bear ate, and clearly he's happy,
but I didn't eat.
Generally I'll go for some oatmeal,
but I'm not afraid of
doing intermittent fasting.
Sometimes I wake up, I don't
have much of an appetite,
I do intermittent fast,
but let's get the Lenovo smart assistant,
powered by Google, to
help us out this morning.
Hey Google, show me a recipe for oatmeal.
- [Google Assistant]
Here are some recipes.
- Ah, hot.
Smells good though.
The reason you see me put so
many fruits into my oatmeal,
is because I want it to taste good
and instead of putting sweeteners in,
I'd rather just put in more fruits
because if fruits
vitamins, minerals, fiber
so you don't absorb as
readily all of the sugars,
I think that's the best way to do it.
Mm, that's really good.
Want a bite?
Bear wants a bite.
But Bear wants a bite of anything.
I take Bear on a walk every morning,
somewhere around 15, 20 minutes.
He needs a nice long walk,
so that when he's at home
during the day alone,
he doesn't destroy the entire house.
That's a mistake I see people make a lot.
If you saw my previous
morning routine video,
I was doing some
calisthenics in the morning.
Now, I got this stationary bike,
so I'm cycling pretty much every morning.
Get to do like 20, 30 minutes
of solid interval training
so my heart rate gets
better, burn some calories,
keep the weight off, all
without losing muscle.
I always tell my patients,
you don't need to spend
a lot of time exercising
in order to lose weight.
One thing I have to do
every morning is do my hair.
As you saw earlier in the
video, my hair's a mess
when I wake up.
The only way I can get it
normal is through blow drying.
I use a little heat protecting spray
just because I'm blow
drying my hair very often.
And then, I let the blow
dryer let the magic happen.
And a simple round brush.
(hair dryer blowing)
Keeping it simple, get
a little hair product,
clay or pomade, whatever you like using
and then let it work its magic.
Every morning, before I set out to work,
I like to sit right here on this couch
for like five minutes, just focusing,
and I know a lot of successful
people like to meditate,
but this isn't about sitting cross-legged
with your fingers touching.
This is about being mindful.
Thinking about what's in your unconscious.
I know that sounds deep,
but it's really about thinking about
what emotions are you feeling?
What are you feeling them about?
What's bothering you?
And when you connect those feelings
and you're true about how you feel,
you can be so much more
productive throughout your day.
I've definitely noticed a benefit,
and it's something I
recommend to you at home.
Now I need to get dressed for work
and depending on where
I'm working that day,
I have to put on a different outfit.
For example, if I'm going
on TV to do the news,
I have to put on the full suit and tie.
If I'm gonna be working
the hospital that day,
I put on slacks, dress shirt, tie
and then finally, if I'm
working the urgent care,
I throw on my scrubs,
'cause I don't want to
get my own clothes dirty.
I think it's really important
that you feel comfortable
in what you're wearing because it shows.
You become more comfortable
and when you dress like a professional,
you get treated like a professional.
Time to go to the hospital, but first,
let me check the traffic.
Hey Google, what's traffic
like going to work?
- [Google Assistant] On your way to work,
traffic is light as usual.
It is 35 minutes by car.
You can see the full
directions on your phone.
- Thanks Google.
So there you have it guys.
My morning routine is
about to come to and end.
I'm ready to get to the hospital.
Don't wanna be late,
because I have patients
and I'm working til really late.
Now the last thing in my morning routine
is the drive into work,
and ever since I was a
kid, I loved sports cars
and driving, but now I'm
fortunate enough to have one.
Now if you wanna share some
of your morning routine tips,
or something you do
unusual in the morning,
drop it down below in the comments.
Huge thanks to Lenovo for
sponsoring this video,
and letting me keep the Smart Display.
The Lenovo Smart Display
allows you to navigate
and command YouTube with
the power of your voice.
So you can pull up my videos,
even when you've got your hands full
and the audio is fantastic,
so you can listen to
music when you workout
or meditate in the morning.
Now don't forget to send me comments
and share your morning habits down below.
You know I love responding to you guys
both in the comments section
and in my monthly responding
to comments video.
Stay happy and healthy.
You know, when you're
feeling down sometimes,
you just need a compliment.
Hey Google, give me a compliment.
- [Google Assistant]
You should write a book
about how to be amazing.
It would be a best seller.
- Aw, that's so sweet.
(upbeat music)